foreign
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host teacher mizzouz this is a another
installment of our early on in
recruitment series I'm joined by Becca
from umata uh who we're gonna sort of
dive into her journey so far but we're
just talking before this and we wanted
to just give all of you just some useful
context so
um Becca for the last year has been
building her career at umata and
recently had her year Milestone so
that's what we're going to be really
digging uh into today but what sort of
interesting I've certainly find
interesting as part of this story is
about four years ago
um Becker actually got into the
recruitment industry
to joined the business where she was
doing contract construction recruitment
she did that for four to six months and
actually for the recruitment is not for
her and she left the industry Becca then
went back into Hospitality for a couple
of years before then joining umata in
2021 so I think what's really cool about
this is Becca's still early on in her
journey but actually had yeah a prior
recruitment experience that could have
potentially meant that Becca hasn't then
gone on to have this amazing journey of
you matter so far so I think this is
yeah an interesting one and I guess part
of this episode is just to educate some
of you that just because your first job
in recruitment maybe didn't work out
um there's a few things that Becca's
going to share that could get you
thinking about
um what could make a successful
um career and recruitment if things
didn't work out initially so I guess
Becca where I've been starting and and
why I wanted to give that context is how
has I guess recruitment with you matter
in this sort of last year maybe compared
to what you expected from from your
previous experience let's let's not
there
yeah so um
I know that recruitment unfortunately
sometimes has a bad stigma around it and
I think the experience that I had kind
of made sense and it proves as to why
sometimes it does
um but yeah like what I really think in
regards to that experience that I had
um it was awful I started
um three months I did resourcing I was
on a really low basic and I didn't even
actually get any commission for placing
sort of anywhere between 5 and 15
construction workers into their job
every day
um and and yeah to me I was surrounded
by people that didn't really give me any
guidance and um and didn't really look
like they enjoyed their job either so
um it wasn't something that I lasted
very long in when I got promoted and I
was doing BD I was just left in my eye
to do it didn't make like 20 30 cold
calls a day and and see where it caught
me
um so yeah it wasn't really the best
start but I think when I spoke with
Mitchell uh straight away it was
something that I was really upfronting
or honest about
um recruitment wasn't really quite for
me I'm quite a um
I'm not really modest I like to be the
best at everything I I like to think
that I'm the best at everything that I
do so
um when I wasn't very good at
recruitment I could I just give it up
like I'm like okay I'm not the best so
I'll just stop but
um yeah I think it was more I was more
sold on on the fact that you matter as
well as a lot of other companies are
really trying to change that bad stigma
now and they're really trying to
um put in the good practices and really
understand what recruitment is about and
even now like when I look back to that
previous role I just don't think that
it's even in the same sort of uh like
region of things I don't see recruitment
then and recruitment now is the same at
all like I'm building relationships now
like I have a team that really
collaborate and work together so I think
um about something that I wanted to come
and hear and really talk about is not
only understanding recruitment coming
into recruitment but understanding um
particularly like what sector you're
going into whether you want to work in
like a permanent work or contract work
or like yeah like whether it's a
long-term goal
I'd definitely say as much as
um I enjoy my role now it's still
difficult I can't lie and say that it's
it's a lot easier than I thought but
um I think now about the highs
definitely outweigh the lows with this
job
yeah I love that so I guess just to I
guess let's just start just really
quickly then just because you you shared
some really good stuff there
um before I start asking you about your
first year with you matter
like for people that might be listening
to this that might be in there like
similar to you first couple of months
um and might sort of be thinking
recruitment is not for me I guess
knowing what you know now and you've
obviously got the benefit of this whole
experience you've had of you matter that
you you may not have known existed
um
like what advice would you give to
people that may be thinking no
recruitment is not for me but obviously
you've experienced that actually getting
the right company the right sector has
really helped you so I don't know is
there anything that you would maybe say
to people to consider or things that you
would encourage them to do just before
they decide to hang up their uh yeah
boots I've been recruitment forever
yeah I definitely just really understand
like what it is that's like making them
unhappy in their job like because like
is it the fact that you're working with
contractors I like um sorry construction
workers but I don't want to put a bad
name on just oh yeah sure yeah that's my
experience and like even doing BD like
that you're speaking to like proper
geezery guys that just if if they get a
cold call like they're just going to
hang up then they don't really care so
um to me like that sector wasn't really
great for myself like is it the team
that you're around again I was
surrounded by people that were 10 plus
years older than me
um and yeah just seemed like they didn't
really have nice job or motivation
themselves like really understand what
it is that's making you unhappy there
and and just look around that
recruitment's huge like there's what
like 40 000 recruitment companies in the
UK
um like you need to understand that like
the com like recruitment as a whole is
an insane platform and it can do
wonderful things for you but like you
need to understand like that different
companies are all doing different things
like even now with the amount of where a
startup company is something I've never
worked in before but it gives me a lot
of like driving it gives me a mission as
well to work on
yeah I love that I think yeah if you're
and hopefully a part of this can educate
people on that but I think that's great
advice I think if you're listening right
now and you are unhappy take a step back
and recognize what it is that you are
unhappy with
um because saying I don't like
recruitment there's probably peel back
the onion on that because there might be
a few things in there that actually you
by making uh speak to other companies or
there'll be other things that you can
control like the sets you recruit in the
people that you're working with like
that's part of working in recruitment
but they're actually things you can
influence by getting into the right
company
um so okay
awesome so let's get into this then so
why was La asking Becker is like what
what skills were experiencing has
recruitment given you that maybe you you
least expected to get from from this
career so far
um I think it's uh quite an obvious one
it is my confidence and it's it's crazy
because I've had confidence grow in like
every area of what I do like I I worked
like at theme park and I had to speak to
like thousands of different people every
day so I I've built Confidence from that
but like now I have confidence in like
talking about software development and
coding languages and and just give me
the confidence to understand that I can
be an expert in whatever field that I
want to
um I mean if a confidence is something I
always thought I had but it just really
just made me put it into a whole new
practice and yeah just times the
confidence that I have
um by mile definitely I love this and
how is that have you also seen that show
up in your personal life
um
I can't imagine I could have got more
confident fair enough
no no it definitely has but there's
there's stuff now that I'm I'm achieving
that I I never do before like it's it's
given me the confidence to like even
start my own mortgage process like
that's something that wasn't even on the
cards for a long long time for me and
it's and yeah it's pushed me into like
adult life really I guess what I take
from that is like it's real you you're
someone who's confident but being in the
environment that you've been in and the
career and recruitment it's it seems
like what I'm getting is showing you
that you're capable even more or like
yeah the chance to adapt to all the
different certain like situations like
I'm never ever in a million years
thought that I'd be able to talk
like yeah like coding and software
development but yeah it just made me see
that you can really adapt to anything
okay so so let me ask you then what what
has in this year then what because
obviously you had some previous context
and experience what what has been maybe
more challenging in your first year than
than you expected
um I'd say
really like the lows
recruitment and they they do come out of
nowhere
um I'd say you can't like their
unexpected I know that I was on like
such a high and I was um billing like
every single month and I was really
lucky to start off when I did but I
think one month I had
five or six rejected offers and to me
that was that was crazy like I thought
if I got any offer at any point like I
can close it that's no problem and then
yeah like five or six rejected offers in
a month and I was thinking this is going
to be my first month like getting way
over like a five figure paycheck like
it's gonna be it's going to be fantastic
and then yeah it just comes out of
nowhere and it is it hits you hard
um but yeah like that was a huge
challenge for me and again it's just a
point for me to step back and look at
everything and just think
um like where can I improve like what's
really like like is there anything that
I could have done or is it just the
industry and sometimes it is sometimes
you could have made improvements but you
just learned from it
so let's just talk about this for a
moment not to sort of make you relive a
horrible moment
but I think this is what you're talking
about is something that a lot of people
go through and can be a real Catalyst as
to why people leave the industry so you
just mentioned they're about having the
right mindset towards it in terms of
like right what can Becca learn what can
you do differently next time what can
you improve on but thinking about that
month like I said already maybe worked
out what it is you're going to get paid
maybe you're thinking about how much you
can save towards your mortgage from that
paper or you can spend the money on to
then having those rejected offers and
and happening is really difficult to
swallow like what what did you what did
you do to like work for it like what
like what did you have to do to make
sure that your whole month you didn't
spend dwelling on what could have been
like did you go out and go for a walk
like I don't know what what did you do
that to help you get out of that
potential funk
um
well I'd always say like you've been
busy like is is the best thing but
definitely just step back and look at
each situation as a separate situation
like when it comes to the month I did
look back and I think wow that was five
five offers there just like that's tough
but each as it comes like you need to
just understand each different situation
as its own situation and then
um just shake it off and and think of
the next day as the next day and
something that I find super motivating
like I don't know how many
um sort of like managers or Founders
will be listening to my first year but
those one-on-one interview uh one-on-one
um uh training sessions or one-on-one
meetings that you have with your founder
with your
um your Mentor like I find them super
helpful like just to sit down and really
get everything off your chest uh how
you're feeling and not only that like
here that it's not just you that you're
you're founder that bill and like a
million pound in a year like he's had
the same thing like he's had more than
that like going wrong and he is where he
is now I'm fine that's super motivating
for myself
and from that from that month what was
what was like the key takeaway or key
learning that that you took away from I
know that I know that it is quite
contextual or whatever but is there
anything that comes to mind that you
like you know what that's something I
really learned from that period that I
really like always have to do now or
something that you always keep top of
mind
yeah I'd say that just
um be so assertive that you are an
expert maybe not in the field but you're
an expert in Recruitment and you're an
expert in finding people what they are
what they are looking for I had the main
one for me was uh one candidate that I
introduced to a role
um I knew he'd be perfect for it and he
was like no no like it's a bit too big
of a company I want a smaller company
and I you know and I said to him like
there's a couple of your previous
colleagues that's gone to this company
like I really think that you'll add
value and I think that you could be a
really big asset and he was like no no
it's okay and I sent him the details
anyway and he was like yeah like maybe
and I was like why don't you speak with
your your old colleague and he'll let
you know that it's a good role and then
he managed to actually be introduced to
the company through that colleague
myself
um and if I had just like been so
assertive and been like I know that this
is a good role like I'm going to
introduce you because like it's a
fantastic role for you that that would
have been in my pocket but he did end up
joining the company after me actually
helping him through the process because
I mean when he asked me about the
interview process I'm not gonna lie or
I'm not gonna try and shock him and send
him to my company like I wanted to help
him like find the right role and I ended
up doing all my job for free of charge
yeah no that that's really interesting
one actually yeah just I guess again
confidence right and being like no no
Becca the recruiter knows that this is
where you should go this is why yeah
that's really interesting thanks for for
sharing that so I guess
what what did you what have you maybe
learned then uh bringing it back to uh
maybe things
um sort of early on on that like what
what did you learn in your first six to
12 months or the last six twelve months
that maybe you wish you knew from day
one
um yeah I think again
um I don't want to sound like a broken
record but you need to understand that
you are an expert in that recruitment
like I know that there's so many
different fields out there and not
everyone's going to understand like even
people that recruit for like nurses or
um like yeah construction workers you're
not going to understand like all the ins
and outs of what they do
um but yeah you need to just understand
the process like grow with each
candidate from your first ever candidate
through the process and understand how
their process is so you can tell it from
both sides I think
and like you mentioned being an expert a
couple of times so let me know what you
think about this but
when I speak to a lot of people through
uh recruitment mentors early on
sometimes I feel like they can sort of
get in their own way and have I don't
know just sort of prevent themselves
from having that confidence and then
being an expert and say things like oh
like this senior software developers
will know way more than me I'm a new
Junior recruiter these types of things
so how how did you how have you really
lent into like being confident around
being an expert because I think a lot of
people feel like it that's going to take
time and I can't be that confident until
I get to this certain positions you know
what I mean so you mentioned it a few
times how have you got better at not
saying to be saying to yourself like oh
I've only got six months I'm not that
much of an expert like to get what I
mean because you can quite easily fall
in for that no I completely understand
I've been the exact same I'd say like
just being so genuine and honest from
from the get-go like even if you're in
your first like month you just be like
okay look I'm very new to this company
I'm very new to recruitment but
um I know that we've got some fantastic
opportunities in the market right now if
you're looking for this opportunity like
we have
um incredible roles
um I'd love to discuss with you and find
out what it is that you're looking for
and then I'll go back and I'll make sure
that this matches with that like you you
don't need to
um yeah again you don't need to be an
expert in what you're selling you just
need to know that you're doing the right
thing for that person like even when it
comes to to BD
um like they understand that you're not
the developer themselves or you're not
the
um like
to ever candidate themselves you need to
just understand what it is that you're
here for and how you're going to help
them get to where they want to be
so yeah yeah honestly I love that and
what do you think you do you think
you've done anything to speed up that
process do you think you've really gone
above and beyond to like getting to that
point where you are more like so I get
that owners look I am new to this but
like you said be honest I'm here for
your best intentions and these types of
things but do you think you've done
anything personally to really accelerate
yeah I'd say that um just like
um getting your personality across like
even when it comes to your personal
branding
um I've gained clients through personal
branding I've gained lots of candidates
with personal branding and I see a lot
of people out there posting stuff that's
really relevant to their sector but
again those candidates know that they
don't actually know anything about the
sector whatsoever so it's just quite
false I think when you get your
personality across and uh yeah really
like even as recruitment what you're
doing is telling a person you're not
selling all of their
um all of their expertise I can write a
whole CBR but when I send the candidate
I'll be like if I'm honest like I know
that they might be a little bit Junior
but what really sold me was the
confidence that they had and their
personality and enthusiasm to learn
um I think as long as you sell yourself
as a person it's the exact same as what
you're doing uh day to day or selling
candidates to the to the company
love it so um obviously you've you've
gained
um a number of promotions in in your
last year obviously if I'm wrong so
obviously you're I don't know how long
for how long for but obviously you've
been doing the sort of client and
business development side right yeah in
the past how long has that been I'd say
mainly just this year really so in the
past like eight months hey Mom it's cool
okay so I guess curious to find this out
you just mentioned around around
um personal branding but what what has
been sort of your own experience and
your best way of firstly cultivating and
building sustainable client
relationships what has ended up being
the sort of best way for you to achieve
that has it been personal branding has
it been a mixture of the phone good
emails I don't know what was ended up
really working for you
yeah it's not a mixture of everything
really
um I think having your personal brand
always putting out as much as you can
um to get your personality and the way
that you are across
um just things that you do in your home
life I think people want to know the
people that they're working with
um I did start out just posting
um as much as I can about tech and as
much as I could about scholar but um it
only ever really was the the people at
umata that was lagging or interacting
um but yeah I think the one post where I
probably put my personality across the
most and posted a disgusting photo of
myself like they actually went viral and
that's where I gained a couple of client
calls and um and a lot of candidates
from that as well
um but yeah I'd say even from the get-go
when I introduced myself to people I've
started introducing video calls again
you can get so much more personality
across than you can on a cold call than
you can on an email
um but yeah just trying to be there and
be present as much as you can when it
comes to Cooling and just to catch up
with them or booking in
um
every other week and just catching up on
the pipeline you want to yeah just stay
um
stay personable with these guys
definitely
yeah I'm definitely getting that and I
think sometimes sometimes these are the
sorts of things that
people early on in their career feel
like uh they can't share these things or
like I don't know are too concerned or
worried about that but clearly that's
been yeah one of the some of the best
things that you've done and that's what
I'm sort of getting sort of learning in
this conversation is that you really
lend into like bringing the full Becca
to work and bringing your personality
and connecting with people on a human
level and that's actually ended up being
becoming your competitive advantage or
has ended up actually really impacting
your results
if you ever have the opportunity to turn
up conferences and meetups or anything
like that I'd highly recommend it it's a
great way to interact with with those in
your sector
so what what's been interested to hear
this from you what's been like the best
training advice that maybe you've got
from Mitch or Jay or other people in the
business what's been the best trending
advice that you've received that's
really worked for you since starting it
could be anything and feel free to go as
Grand as you want but I don't know
there's anything stick out
yeah well there's one thing that me and
Mitchell actually started looking into
um very recently
um he has mentioned it quite a lot
throughout my time at umata but we've
really started to dig into it quite
recently now that I the year mark but
your data behind what you're doing is
incredible like now I've been here for a
year I can really look at how many
candidates that I've subbed to get my
one deal or how many interviews that
it's taken me to get that one deal and
now I can start looking at things at a
whole new perspective I could really
look like okay well if it takes me nine
interviews to get one deal then I need
to make sure that I'm doing nine
interviews a week or nine interviews
every other week so that I'm getting at
least two deals a month or
um or even looking at things like okay
well if I did the same amount
um of deals I'm doing now but I just did
them in my own
client then I'm doubling my Billings
anyway it's incredible like what you can
really look back at and it goes really
far back as well I think even if I
started maybe two months in and I was
looking at how many profiles that I
looked at to send out the amount of
messages that I need to or how many
messages that I sent out to
um to get on as many candidate calls as
I want to if you start looking back and
start going through all this you can
really start leveraging how much work
you're doing and leveraging like working
smarter than rather than harder I guess
but I think if anyone can really get in
touch with whoever looks after all of
that it's definitely worth going through
that's that's so interesting so what I'm
getting from that you're probably the
first person to to say this what I'm
getting from that what what is that what
you seem quite excited by that so like
what is that enable you to do because
what I'm getting from that and you let
me know what you think but it's enabling
you to really understand the science
behind what it is that you need to do
and have even more clarity on what's
going to hopefully get you the outcomes
and and the results that you want
because I think obviously early on it is
very much just like I don't know I need
to crack on with this I need to do this
or whatever but as you like you said as
you gain more and more experience
there's more and more data that you can
look at it can actually really get a
grasp of what's required to achieve X
outcome so it seems like it's enables
have even more clarity on what Becca
needs to do to achieve the goals that
you want is what I'm getting from that
yeah massively I mean it's um really put
things into
how much money that I've made this year
I'm super happy with like all I'm going
to do really is maintain it but I know
um I know now what I need to do to
double that and for me even if I was to
perhaps go on holiday next week all I
need to know is how much how many
interviews that I need to get before I
go on holiday and how many interviews I
need to get after I go on holiday to
just maintain the level that I'm at I
don't need to go on holiday for a week
and then stress when I get back thinking
oh I'm so behind like I haven't got this
many interviews I haven't done this when
it's like okay well now I know the
numbers that I need to have before I go
and I know the numbers I need to foreign
that as I come back and I don't need to
stress about it at all because I know as
soon as I've got those nine interviews
I've got my deal like I don't need to
stress like that's how many interviews
has taken me to get a deal and that's
that's not yeah no I love that because
particularly now as you as you've been
as you all know doing the client the
candidate side 360 side there's a lot
going on right there's a lot you can be
prioritizing these things so I think
that's a really interesting Insight
because that can oftentimes be the
boring part then there's an admin these
types of things but actually what it's
enabled you to do is just have complete
Clarity on what Becca needs to do and
it's going to give you like you said
more confidence to know that right I've
I know I've done that so it should mean
this it still may not happen but I know
that I've really put in the inputs and
the tube what I needed to to get close
to or achieve the outcomes that you
wanted yes that's really interesting so
I've done a few experienced this but did
you have you experienced like a penny
drop moment like the one where you
really felt like you got it since being
with you matter do you think you had one
of those moments where things really
clicked for you
um
I don't know it really happened maybe
two or three times and then and then
I've been like oh okay maybe not not
quite so much yeah
um but yeah I think really when I got a
real grasp on my candidate management
and I really
um yeah just not looking so much on
um like I need to get 25 Subs in a week
like and just trying to win out how many
Subs I get like it's really like you
need to help these guys through the
process like they need that extra
guidance before every every call that
they go into they need some assistance
when it comes to like
um like managing what they're looking
for salary expectations or what else it
is that they need like they need that
so kind of Imagine a big fee okay so
what about this then obviously I know
you've had a really good
first year so I guess if you if you were
to start
your journey all over again
knowing what you know now how would you
approach your first 90 days
differently if at all I would say
probably I would
I'll chill out a bit on my first month I
think I went in again very confident
really cocky thinking to do a deal
straight away like I'm not stressed when
really that first month it should just
really be a write-off you need to
consume as much as you can take in
everything from everyone you speak to I
think that I was really really lucky
starting off when I did in the in our
startup because the people I was
shadowing was Jay and Mitch so I was
lucky to have whatever what I still
think I'm probably the best recruiters
out there to take as much as I could
from them but now as we grow our team
like they're even more luckier because
they get to take the best parts of what
everyone does and make a mega recruiter
and just really put all of those best
things into practice so yeah just really
just take that first month to learn and
again
on those 90 days keep track of
everything I did so much on my notepad
and wasn't really bothering too much
with the CRM
um but now I would love to have all of
those notes back and to really be able
to track my data even more because I'd
have every single thing on there
yeah that's interesting so it'd be
interesting to get get your thoughts on
this because of your previous experience
but
like if you could pick one thing about
the environment that you've joined so
that you matter that you feel like has
really allowed you to succeed
what do you think it would be so like I
don't know it could be culture training
incentives the right market like what
what is it that you feel like that
you've experienced that maybe people
should really look for in a company when
entering recruitment
I say culture is a massive massive one
um as everyone knows those lows are
horrible like when those all those
things go wrong it's not great but
having like a team that you know you can
fall back on you know really understand
what you're going through and we'll be
there to help you through everything and
that's really important for me
um again the training is incredible you
need that training in recruitment if you
want to go as far as as you can
um yes recruitment is a great industry
to go into if you want to earn lots of
Lots unless you're being trained
tomorrow like you're just gonna want to
leave after three to six months really
so final question then
why why do you think more people should
consider recruitment as a career choice
um I mean it's hard to picture much else
than money I think there's a lot of
other things that you can say
um you you change multiple people's
lives like within like a month within a
week
um but yeah I think there's no better
place to start out if you want to earn
as much money as possible like if you do
have genuine Ambitions and genuine
reasons to earn that much money like
you'll have the Thrive to really go for
it
um like I think last month I paid more
in taxes than I've ever ever earned in
In Like A month's work and that's just
because of how much that you put in I
know like everything that you do you're
going to get out as much as you put in
but I think recruitment is probably the
best way to do that
love that we'll look back I'll
absolutely love your story obviously
going going from the your experience
leaving the industry coming back and
then it sounds like you've just really
maximized the opportunity and that
you've been given and then also I just
love hearing the recruitments ultimately
sort of just enabled you to go you know
what Becca's capable of even more
um and you've really lent into yeah I
guess pushing the boundaries of what you
think is possible and what things that
you you think you can achieve I think
that's one of the amazing things in
recruitment right that like you said put
put the work in and you can see you get
what it is that you put in uh but yeah I
absolutely love this so look thank you
so much for for joining me and and
sharing those things well I was really
excited to share this with everyone and
I know yeah you're always happy to
connect with people on LinkedIn and
these things for people that might be
struggling or may have some questions
for you but yeah thank you so much for
being part of the series
thank you for having me speaker